we are here today for the new era group
meeting we will welcome for the first
time Christine Lagarde as the new
president of the ECB we all know
Christine for a long time already and
it's very good to have her now in this
new role and I'm looking forward to work
with her in the coming years we also
continue the renewal of the ECB board we
have to replace AB in Latin schlager
it's very good that they will may
welcome
Albert Bravo this specialist in
innovation investment that will make a
presentation to ministers and I expect a
very lively discussion around this very
important theme in the inclusive format
we will continue our debate on how to
strengthen the Euro our institutions are
much stronger today we've done a lot of
work in the recent years on this subject
but we know that we have to continue and
to complete the banking union today we
will also discuss the reform the ESM
reform and we have a great contribution
this week coming from Germany as you
know we established three working groups
at our deputy levels led by Denmark
Germany and Spain these working groups
are expected to produce documents that
will contribute to our decision in
December to design the roadmap for
political discussions on Nidhi's that
will continue next year
you